hey guys i'm off the grid for august but
joe scarborough is still taking every
side of every issue depending on who's
in power
well you say appeasing the public you're
talking about appeasing
conspiracy theorists
insurrectionists
weirdos crazy people freaks
fast
fascists who are now going online
talking about violence against the
federal judge uh these are people like
you said
you're never you're never gonna win with
this group but you know you you look at
the people that are squawking the
loudest they're the people
it's you know it's what you expect
someone who's guilty and know that
justice is about to come down on them
it's but it's how you expect them
to squawk so
i really i i think there's way too much
chatter
uh about uh the concern about these
right
wing extremists and fascists i think you
call fascist fascists and if people are
and if fascists are going out making
threats
um
uh uh i think what you do is you know
you you go after them uh with the law
and there's that but there's also rule
of law and if you have
people on uh cable news channels that
inspired violence uh leading up to
january the sixth and then were shocked
on january the sixth
by the violence that took place and then
after january 6th pretended like they
weren't shocked by the violence that
took place on january 6 and they're
doing it again
well
you know they're they're legal channels
for that too when people uh obviously
get hurt there's they're being very
reckless of being irresponsible but
there's an underlying theme about what's
been going on in trump world since
january
6 the investigation really took off and
this this is the thing
he's not being taken down politically or
legally